it's not quite noon but i see that
there's already a lot of questions so
i thought i would uh pop in just a
little bit early and get us rolling
so um some first-time amar's here that's
that's uh nice welcome to you and
scrolling down i see that
mark is here good to see you mark and a
few familiar
names not faces of course among the
people asking questions so
let me
take the first question first
this is from ben feltz what are your
thoughts on plato's laws does it
recontextualize the republic
anything i should keep an eye out for
while reading plato's laws
yeah i mean re-contextualize
that is a
that's a good way to put it
i mean i think a lot of people do take
plato's republic
as kind of his definitive statement
about
uh political life and stuff like that
you know putting aside the fact that
there's lots of other dialogues that um
bring up political matters if the
gorgeous is a prime example
you know
we could think of
the statesmen as well so the laws for
those who don't know the context here
the laws is plato's
last work and
it is um
we'll say we'll say it's controversial
how to
assess it and interpret it
within the scholarly literature
vindlebond i remember
said um he called it plato's
old you know latest and most senile work
if i remember right i was always struck
by that and so you know there's a
tendency among scholars some scholars to
say
um
you know it's not as good as the earlier
stuff and then there's others who are
like
towards the end of his life plato
you know
became less interested in crafting great
literature
and he was willing to like lay things on
the table
so you know and then you've got
everything in between and i myself you
know i'm
i'm the kind of person that when it
comes to plato
interpretation i like to try to as i
think you know was was quite common
among ancient platonists i like to try
to harmonize what it is that plato is
saying
in from one dialogue to the next without
you know saying that everything is is
one perfect seamless
garment you know so to speak um there
are some tensions between the works but
i would say yeah recontextualize that
that's a good way to
put it and not just recontextualize the
laws is much much longer and and much
more
detailed in some of its
recommendations than the
quite long republic is
and so
it's it's adding a lot to the to the
picture and it's it's i think it's well
worth the read
um
anything i should keep an eye out for
while reading the laws
i don't really have any advice about
that i will say this
if you've read plato
you know the republic and you've read
aristotle's um politics and you know
connected to that the we could call them
the broader ethical political works like
the rhetoric and the two through ethics
and you know things like that um
then you've got
uh a work that's kind of
in between there in the laws
it's in some respects um
more like
aristotle's politics books um
like five through seven you know
where he's he's detailing the
the nuts and bolts of how things get put
together so that's that's probably
enough on that uh galen says in the
field of philosophy of religion do you
think analytic or continental
philosophers have been more successful
in adapting their school to the field
and i do know your feelings on the
analytic continental divide thing i've
seen your stuff on it's been helpful so
you know the reference there
my view is that the analytic continental
divide is something
rather
limited and provincial it reflects a
uh division between two
different
groupings within philosophy that don't
reflect the entire field of philosophy
it's fairly recent in providence and
probably will not be around 100 years
from now when you know it's it'll be as
quaint as you know the the big divide
between uh british empiricists and
continental rationalists which we know
is kind of a
not really that true you know i mean
there were there were continental
empiricists and they were
locke is quite rationalist in his own
way so um you know my view on the
analytic uh continental divide is that
it leaves out so much
other stuff right and i kind of think
this with philosophy of religion i mean
you can do philosophy of religion
existed before the analytic continental
divide
and it was being done before it was even
being called philosophy of religion
so i i think that's well worth taking
into account there now
this is kind of an interesting question
who's been more successful in adapting
their school to the field
it depends on what you mean by
successful
like are we talking about dominating the
textbook industry
or
um
getting you know the more conferences
and stuff like that i mean analytic
philosophy is dominant this is going to
be a tautology right analytic philosophy
is dominant where analytic philosophy is
dominant so if you
if you pick a place where most people
have been trained in the analytics
school and then people happen to be
doing philosophy of religion
most of the people doing philosophy of
religion are going to be
of that bent you know um
[Music]
you know i i would say society of
christian philosophers and their
their journal fide serazio
unless i'm mistaking it i might be
mixing it up with another journal um
you know pretty analytic right planting
was a big name and that that for a long
time
um
[Music]
who counts as continental because you
know if you're thinking about
european philosophy and people studying
it over here and applying it over here
it's not just the cutting edge
trendy stuff it includes hegel who you
know has lectures on the philosophy of
religion it includes uh you know
phenomenologists like mock shaler you
know it includes people like maurice
blondell um who often don't get ready
includes uh gabriel marcel and we could
go on and on and on and on right
it also includes all those neo-tomists
even though they don't fit neatly into
that spectrum so it's kind of a hard
question to answer
so mark uh says
uh thoughts on something like a bios
musicos
as a life devoted to music as techne
what are some elements you feel are
important to the excellent life of the
heavy metal musician
ama is always fun so a boss musicos you
know a
this is kind of a double meaning thing
right its literal meaning is a musical
life a life i suppose you could say that
is
oriented by and filled by music
so
that could be everything from
deliberately studying music and working
in that field to being
part of a musically inclined family as
my my mother's entire side of the family
was um
you know there's all sorts of stories
that could be told about that my great
grandfather
actually organized a a band and got a
hold of instruments and taught like
all the instruments to all the band
members and and we you know we've been a
singing and harmonizing family and lots
of people with musical
talent um so is that a bios musicos it
can also mean
if we go back to ancient times
so music
along with
gymnastics is one of the main ways of
teaching and tempering the
human being right so look at plato's
republic we started out talking about
plato's republic
music
music is one of those things that is
being
learned being studied
in part two
to
temper the soul but it includes more
than music in that case it includes
the lyrics it includes the other stuff
so now now
jumping ahead
to the to you know the future for them
at the present for us
um musicians professional musicians
um it's
is it a technique is it a skill is it an
art yeah definitely
um but there's more to it so you know
i've got this friend
scott chiruli who many of you have seen
me you know do classic metal class with
and he is a professor at berkeley school
of music and berkeley school of music is
sort of like the place where i teach
milwaukee institute of art and design or
the place where my wife has taught and
worked for the culinary institute of
america
it's a professional school so it's
turning out people who are going to be
going into
a creative profession you know
music or you know culinary arts or art
and design and then you take a lot of
other classes to help you
contextualize that to if we're going to
use these categories of techne you could
say that part of the goal is also also
to impart
other
types of knowledge like uh prudence and
um
you know disciplinary knowledge that
counts as as epistemy and i and i think
that um to be good as a musician you
don't necessarily need those things but
they have a good life so to go back to
the
uh
bios part of this you you do need those
those things and a lot of musicians
discover these things you know when you
read biographies of heavy metal
stars like you know uh over the last
couple years i've for example read tony
aomi's
account of being in black sabbath and
you know you you learn
you see him talking about the lessons he
learned along the way like
drugs will mess you up man don't don't
get too involved and self-indulgent in
those you know um those are things that
that become part of
phronesis
or practical wisdom which is is quite
important
uh jamal has kind of a
non-philosophical question here but it
could be turned in philosophical ways
is coffee without cream the same thing
as coffee without milk um
yeah i mean
technically it is i mean it's coffee
without a milk product in it right
i suppose you could say
i got you there you know you don't put
cream in your coffee but you put milk in
your coffee right and we define cream as
having a certain fat content right maybe
oh it's skim milk you know or one
percent milk or something like that
and you could say um you know i've got
coffee with milk in it but not coffee
with cream
yeah okay i guess that that that would
make sense um
i mean
it's a point for me because my coffee
has half and half in it which is a kind
of milk and a kind of cream so
you know
i uh i enjoy those
quite a bit
um
all right let's take the next one uh
oldies how do you reconcile determinism
with moral responsibility
i i don't because i don't believe that
there is a complete determinism
i think that uh things are a little bit
loosey-goosey you know um if you're
asking whether
you know partial causal determinism can
be reconciled with moral responsibility
you say well
what part are we responsible for what
part do we have agency in right
um and and you know various forms of
what we call compatibilism can assert
that there is a
overarching causal determinism and yet
that we are still free and there's lots
of ways to do this if you go back to
like cicero
and augustine
you know um the the answer
tends to be that we are also causes we
are self-moved movers
in some respect even though we are moved
by by other things as well all right
kenya says i've been studying who do
mysticism to help me connect to my
african-american roots
it's helped me it's brought me to find
the power of prayer and i've taken a
logic approach like spiritual
rationalism
yeah i suppose you know i don't know
much about who do um because that's
that's not something that i spent any
time
studying when i was uh
teaching a lot of religious studies
classes i do know a lot about
syncretic um
we can call them african diaspora
religions like mostly the aruba based
ifa ones but you know also voodoon you
know which you know there's
interconnections but then then there's
other things going on in hudu
but i think you can take and this is a
broader issue any sort of approach like
that you can take and say all right like
you said rationalize it
what does the system itself look like
will that map on to what actual
practitioners say and do
probably not that that completely
because it's probably not a matter of
complete consensus
and then you've got the question of well
how much of this is like
you know imaginary stuff uh which could
have a good placebo effect or something
but you know ultimately doesn't
reference a
you know if we're talking about causal
stuff a world of
real causes
although you know the placebo effect is
causal right um
in a different way
um
and then you can ask well how much of it
is actually on to
something potentially
connected with with other things or that
can be mapped onto it how much of it is
distinctive to that that system so those
are my thoughts on that and any broader
set of ideas
all right uh sunny um
glad to be joining this month ama hope
you and all have a useful and enjoyable
time yeah yeah it should
these are always fun um
someday i should go through these and
like
pick out you know like uh
classes of answers or something if i
have the time
uh alex how familiar are you with the
medieval philosophy philosopher john
scotus irregina familiar you know not
super
uh
versed in his works it's been a long
time since i've i've read
any of his stuff but you know i know
where he fits in i know what his basic
ideas are
um
tractatus or jeremy actually i'll take
this one what is your stance in
epistemology i don't have a stance in
epistemology um i'm not an ism
type of person all that much i'm much
more drawn to like reading
actual texts and and thinkers and then
saying
um yeah i kind of like this idea over
here and maybe i'll reject this i'm
pretty eclectic when it comes to things
so i don't have like a you know official
stance and epistemology
uh trichotis what do you think of uh
chomsky as philosopher
you know
not much um
i you know chomsky is basically known
for
two main things right political
philosophy and once you've heard his
schtick you know what it is
uh at least he's consistent and then
linguistics and i've never really bought
his linguistic stuff back when i was
super into philosophy of language
um
so you know he's he's an okay guy but
i'm not into chomsky so
um logic any thoughts on the philosophy
of consciousness um
yeah i mean
i don't really think much about like
philosophy of consciousness as a field i
think about consciousness and like i
said with with the earlier question
about epistemology
you know i mean i'll read people who
are interested in that or in related
topics you know consciousness is a
fairly recent term
um but you know we can think about
what goes into it from from earlier
thinkers like you know say renee
descartes or you know
i think about aristotle's dianama or the
onsens and the sensible and stuff like
that those are all modes of
consciousness but i don't i don't have a
thought on the philosophy of
consciousness as such
uh erickson what are your thoughts about
philosophy of language and what are some
of your positions within the topic a lot
of people ask me what are my positions i
don't have an awful lot of positions you
know
um as as such
um
i used to be really really into
philosophy of language and i used to be
really into studying languages and you
know looking into
allied fields like linguistics or
semiotics
i think that it's
quite clear that you can't get away from
language
that
you know it i don't buy like the hard we
could call it the hard superior wharf
hypothesis that like you know the
language of a people determines the the
ways in which they can possibly name or
think about or you know act within or
cognize things
but it's sure clear that language you
know and the language that we use
does affect the way that we view things
and you know i think it's a good thing
for people to study
um i will say that i
early on you know
i
really respected ferdinand de saussure's
um
saying
in his
course on general linguistics
that if you want to study language you
need to learn multiple languages that
you cannot generalize
just based on the language that you
happen to have and this is one of the
failures i think of a lot of analytic
philosophy of language that it was
written by people who largely only knew
english or had you know taken a few
french classes or something like that
but didn't really
understand
you know languages
through having studied them and perhaps
even lived in areas where they needed to
speak them
and and get to the point where they had
some facility with it and could begin
you know dreaming in the language or
making the kind of mistakes that native
speakers make in the language so i you
know just like if you were going to do
study philosophy of sports you probably
should actually play some sports i think
if you're going to do philosophy of
language you probably do need to like
you know spend some time in in other
languages um
and it's a very rich field um
you know i think the main reason i wound
up kind of moving out of that
was just getting much more interested in
historical figures you know it's not as
if i've ever totally left it behind
um
dylan says what are your favorite
philosophical works on the subject of
art for example the birth of tragedy
well that's a good one um i'm not you
know a philosophy of art or aesthetics
person
and
i probably you know i mean as the sole
philosopher working at an art and design
school it's really kind of a shame
that i i haven't developed those uh
capacities at this point
and i've never actually produced an
aesthetics class for them which i i
probably ought to get my my act together
and you know devote myself to some
serious study of that i had an
aesthetics class back in in grad school
and i've read some
other people subsequently but it's not
you know it's not a field that i'm
particularly
great at um i mean the birth of tragedy
is a great work right nietzsche does
talk about um art stuff in other places
you know for example
barely oates in um the composer barely
oats he talks about in uh beyond good
and evil if i remember right he's moved
away from wagner by that point
um
i mean i i'm i don't have an awful lot
to recommend tolstoy's book is even
though i disagree with it on a lot of
accounts what is art is is well worth
reading
um i mean there's bits and pieces of
consideration of art throughout you know
the canon you could say
hegel's definitely devoted a lot of
thought to it not just in the aesthetics
but also in you know other
other uh works as well um
but yeah i don't have an awful lot to
say about about that
um
jeremy says hi hi to jeremy
boomer says i've heard you talk about
your eventual disregard of the pursuit
of originality can you talk some more
about that i mean i did a whole video
about that so
um i think i just think that the the
there isn't an eventual disregard of the
pursuit of originality it's just i i
downplay it
you know it's not the
um
highest value that a lot of people
seem to be
aiming at and it winds up being a trap
because very little of what you're going
to do is original in the sense of being
totally unprecedented
you're going to be
you know if you're doing good work
you're going to be incorporating what
other people
are doing as well you know so let me
give you a prime example
of this so i just the book i happen to
have sitting around
uh julia honest uh the morality of
happiness right if you look at the table
of contents and what she's talking about
this is largely
a study
of ancient philosophy right so
there's you know here's the here's the
table of contents at least part of it
right begins with the basic ideas
justification and appeal to nature you
know and she talks about all these
different interesting philosophical
schools and
um you know some some people within them
like for example you know theophrastus
and how they're they're connected to
each other is what she doing here
original
is it unoriginal it's kind of beside the
point it's high quality
very
well researched thoughtful
informative
interpretation of a vast you know
amount of texts and thinkers and so in a
way originality is kind of
besides the point you know
doing solid work that's that's a bit
more important i'd say
um
because
because
there's somebody's got a a name without
any vowels thoughts critique on
spinoza's ethics is anger a passive
state as opposed to an active one
i mean in a way in a certain way every
one of the emotions from spinoza's point
of view is is passive on our parts it's
response right it's not something that
we can
exercise a little bit of control over
ourselves by like bringing to mind
something that can
push our our buttons i mean spinoza is
basically
he's got a what we often call a
mechanistic
way of of approaching the human mind you
know
um
i mean
thoughts on spinoza's ethics so i got a
couple things to say one is people are
always asking me about spinoza
and i think that spinoza and i think
that the ethics
is one of these books
that i will call
a
philosophy
uh
of mystique
meaning by that that
as with like hegel's phenomenology or
phenomenology of spirit or as with
um
khan's critique of pure reason or you
know all the way forward to like nick
land's fang numina
there's a lot of people who
reference these works
don't really understand them
they think they're really cool
they think like you know the secrets of
the universe are in this if i could just
understand it
they never really do understand it
and
they
go back and forth with other people
about this i mean you see it on twitter
constantly
you see it in certain facebook groups
that are devoted to philosophy
and you know my impression is that very
few people who are like into spinoza
really understand spinozas work that
well
um
and it's always the ethics that people
want to talk about it's never it's never
his other works you know like his
principles of cartesian philosophy or
you know um
uh trechtarus uh
theological politicus or anything which
by the way you know borrows some stuff
from from hobbs um
so there's that right there's the the
prestige or mystique factor
um and spinoza himself would have uh
found that
abhorrent i think
um
he he he would want people to actually
like
read and fully understand what the hell
they're reading
that's kind of part of what's in the
book right i mean same thing with hegel
same thing with kant
um
i i mean i find spinoza's point of view
pretty implausible
um
i don't buy his his
overall arguments
and uh but it's interesting and i teach
it uh on occasion you know
and
it can be fun to talk about i don't
think he did himself any favors
by putting it into that weird moragi
metrico kind of format but that that
lends itself to that prestige right just
as much as hegel's
you know
terrible style because he's not a good
stylist um lends itself to that certain
kind of mystique as as well so
yeah so that's basically what i have to
say about spinoza um
and somebody else had uh
uh where is it
did i jump ahead a little bit yeah here
we go
so uh
ally a note oh i get i say it's on top
chat i want it on live chat so i see
everybody's things i think things are a
little bit out of order so allianoic how
necessary do you think life experience
is in regards to being able to
comprehend and digest the works of
philosophers
totally depends on the philosopher we're
talking about you know sometimes um
[Music]
you know so for example there's this
book that i i got years ago that was
sent to me by the publisher i forget
exactly who it's by and i may be
mangling the title but it's it's about
surfing and john paul sartre right
and
one of the criticisms that i would have
of the book is in order to like give a
[ __ ] about you know a lot of the stuff
that's being said you'd have to know
something about surfing and i i actually
know enough to know that i'm not
interested in surfing at all so i didn't
get that much out of that that book and
i actually found a lot of it kind of
pretentious and you know
um off-putting because of that but i
mean there might be some things where
you do need to have some some life
experience it sure doesn't hurt i mean
aristotle thought that it's hard to
teach ethics to younger people in part
because they haven't accumulated enough
certain kinds of life experience so
i think it could be quite quite helpful
um retro gamer says great hegel lectures
recently
exceptionally helpful taxonomy on evil
and the
qualities of thought thanks dr sailor
another vote for spinoza's ethics it's
an anatomy of extroverted feeling
i'm not sure quite what that is but i'm
glad that you found the hegel lectures
useful i don't really remember giving a
taxonomy
on evil but maybe i did i mean i've done
so much so much stuff at one point or
another i'm kind of uh having a hard
time recalling where i where i would
have given a taxonomy of evil in
the
hegel lectures but but maybe i did you
know i mean there's like what
340 something of them out there so
all right era what's the best philosophy
book to read if you've already read the
usual canon for 2022
well you haven't read the usual canon
because nobody's read the whole canon
and remembered all of it so it's worth
going back to parts of the canon i mean
if you think you've read the whole canon
you've uh undoubtedly read a shrunken
cannon there's there's going to be
people that you haven't hit on the way
um who are who are well worth reading i
mean
you know just another book sitting
around if you uh you know
let's go back to ancient philosophy so
how much have you read of the cynics
well you've read lucian's the cynic and
you've read some of xenophon stuff about
you know aristippus that's cool and
you've read
neo-chrysostoms discussions and diogenes
laertes you know book six and
and you've read um
uh justin the emperor's uh piece on the
cynics right well have you read this
the cynic epistles
that should be part of the canon
probably most of us have never heard of
that right by the way nobody nobody in
scholarship actually thinks these are by
the people they're attributed to which
include you know diogenes let's see
diogenes crates heraclitus
uh socrates and anacarsis these aren't
by them but these are an important part
of the literature just as important as
say you know descartes you know let's
say we're talking about descartes you
know so you've read the meditations and
the discourse have you read um
the letters to princess elizabeth the
just you know the the correspondence
with her and the passions of the soul
well no that's that's part of the canon
too so i mean we can always go back to
the canon in general but is there stuff
that you ought to be reading in the
present i mean there's so much stuff
that you can't possibly
read at all right and you might go back
like
like i brought up earlier another book
just sitting around
this is worth reading and in doing so
you're going to be brought into
a fuller understanding of all that
ancient philosophy because you're going
to be
sort of sitting at the lap of a
brilliant
uh
20th and 21st century
uh
thinker who's been you know president of
the apa julia anas you know who's also a
cool person in real life too
um
roughly bumble is a question about
philip k dick is there a philip k dick
story you could recommend to somebody
who reads existentialism but not much
sci-fi just discovered librivox has a
bunch of his stuff
yeah i wonder i mean
so
maybe the statute or not statute of
limitations the copyright has run out on
quite a few of his things well i mean
which of his books don't bring in
existentialist themes the androids dream
of electric sheep right the the
conception of empathy and personhood and
memory that's so important in the
broader existentialist canon
um
you know
there's lots of things that have to do
with
um
what a person is personal identity and
our relationship to
our memories and to we could call it the
theme of the other
and dick actually has quite a few
characters
thinking about things in existentialist
philosophy i mean if you've got a good
local library
there are going to be these library of
america
editions
of philip k dick's works and there's
three volumes
one is like
and they're all like you know four
stories from the 1960s and 70s five
stories from this and that
and uh
those are great you know you you know
you've got like four or five
major novels
in
each of them you know things like
martian time slip or
flow my tears the policeman said or
you know valas or ubek or
um you know uh
um man in the high cast all the all
these really really oh and scanner
darkly which is really one of the best
of his his novels
um
but they're all raising
these themes and you know now that i
think about it
his what are called his realistic novels
are well worth checking out too
like um
in milton lumpke territory
or confessions of a crap artist
those didn't get published in his time
but they i mean the themes that are
being worked with are really quite quite
brilliant so i would check those out
you can also get um collections of his
short stories and that might be what's
on libra box you know
so
all right uh alex did you ever develop
much of an interest in spinoza do you
think you'll ever make any videos about
his works um i never found spinoza
plausible
um
i you know i've never been
i never had a great interest in his
works obviously he fits into the
the vast story of philosophy and so if
you want to understand why leibniz or
why mall branch are doing the things
that they're doing you probably wouldn't
need to know something about spinoza
because they're all trying to avoid
spinozism right at that time
um
but he's kind of like a cul-de-sac you
know i mean there's this talk about oh
you know spider-man had so much
influence on the german idealists
yeah but oftentimes that's like what's
least interesting in their works i think
um and will i ever do stuff on spinoza i
i say this all the time if people want
to commission me to take time out of my
schedule what i'm currently working on
and do stuff on what they're interested
in people have done that for me to do
videos on heidegger nietzsche that they
really wanted to have
people can do that but i don't have any
plans to do spinoza
you know in in the near future because i
think there's there's other works i'd
much rather concentrate on you know
after the half hour hegel
uh videos are all finished
i'm gonna do descartes meditations and
you know look at the latin text and the
french text and and the you know adam
and tannery uh translation
edition and the english and uh go
through that because i think uh that's
more important than spinoza's ethics
um
and then you know we'll see what big
book i want to do after that it could be
you know starts being in nothingness or
heidegger's being in time or something
something else but i mean but if people
want me to do the ethics i i can do it
but
i don't have plans for it myself
fireside says i've recently caught the
philosophy bug any advice to help me be
more industrious
without overloading my amateur brain i
keep a journal that helps process but do
you have your own methodology i do not
have a methodology
i also don't have a methodology when it
comes to exercise you know
um it's not quite like the nike slogan
just do it but you know after
time you you find out what works for you
and you just kind of
make it happen you know
so
um
[Music]
you know i've been studying philosophy
academically now for
more than 30 years
um
so
i don't i don't like have a method and i
don't actually take an awful lot of
notes i i do have a lot of notebooks
that i took you know notes in earlier
and i don't usually go back to them so
so i found it it's not really effective
for me
i will say this though
um this thing is worry about overloading
yourself that can be a definite worry
and oftentimes it's not a matter of like
trying to catch up or make as much
progress as possible because in doing so
so let's say you know take hagel's
phenomenology difficult work right
probably not the first thing you should
read by hegel anyway i always suggest
don't start with the phenomenology
start instead with um
you know the lectures on the philosophy
of history and the lectures on the
history of philosophy and that's not the
only place that you could start but i
think those are good places to start uh
because you know hegel's naming names
and and it's a little bit more
structured and you get to see like what
he makes of of of
the history of philosophy so you kind of
like you figure out his shtick
and what matters to him the most
um
so you know you start with hegel and
you're like i'm going to read the
phenomenology this is great work i've
been missing out on this my whole life
and you open it up and you're like what
the hell is this crap
and then you start making your way
through it and you're like oh i got to
do like you know 50 pages a week because
if i do that i'll be i'll be done with
it by the end of the summer
well
you might do that but then you might you
might
have done better to linger over um some
things or
do some of that and then read somebody
who's a bit easier to to get you know
and then come back to it right it
doesn't have to be this
philosophy shouldn't be reduced to
productivity is is how we should say it
you're never going to read the whole of
what's available anyway
and
you want to find stuff that uh works
with you you know so i've been kind of
knocking spinoza hey if spinoza like
really floats your boat spend time on
spinoza that's fine you know it's not
gonna break your brain or anything
um if if you know it's hegel if it's
nietzsche if it's uh you know julianas
who's written a whole bunch of books um
you just you just keep on doing that and
and don't worry so much there there are
no real benchmarks for whether you're
making adequate progress anybody who
tells you that there are is like trying
to sell some sort of system
and they're they're probably not going
to be that that helpful for you
all right here's another one from uh
kiss vs b
uh any philosophy dealing with feelings
of anger and frustration
i'm 31 i'm afraid of my life i've read
aristotle some nature's stoics but
nothing seems to stick i remain confused
and isolated and angry
so
yeah there's there's a lot of ancient
philosophy that does deal with anger and
it's not usually except for a few works
it's not usually lined up
in such a way as to like give you a
perfect guidebook about it first so for
example
you've read aristotle yes but
aristotle actually has a lot to say
that's quite useful about anger but he
doesn't have a treatise on anger
um
some of what he says is in the nick of
mccann ethics book four
and in the udamian ethics book three
right and those more or less line up
with each other then there's a whole
discussion of it in rhetoric book two
there's discussions of it popping up in
on the soul in
uh topics book three
in
the politics
um
the poetics and
indeed even in statistical refutations
right so you have to like
bring all this stuff together and even
then aristotle's not giving you like
okay do this exercise do this exercise
the way like for example the stoics are
or the way that plutarch is
but aristotle can be quite hopeful
in thinking about how it is that you get
angry and what's going on with that
right
um
the stoics have a lot seneca has a whole
book on anger right epictetus has
discussions of anger so does marcus
aurelius
um
and then there's there's you know some
interesting discussions of it in some
summaries of stoic doctrine cicero has
some useful things to say
plutarch has a whole book
devoted to
controlling anger
and plutarch is in the middle platonist
tradition
and then you know there's other stuff in
antiquity
coming from for example
jewish and christian literature you know
john cassian uh the great monastic
author has some some great stuff about
anger
in his um conferences and institutes
augustine has some very useful stuff to
say about anger
and and this continues on through the
middle ages because there were a lot of
angry people so there's a lot of
reflection
on that descartes himself and on the
passions of the soul has cool stuff to
say about anger
um and so we could go on and on and on
so there are a lot of there are a lot of
people in philosophy who have have good
stuff
to say but
then you have to like you know figure
out how you're going to
appropriate it
and apply it um
and
that's that's often where where it's
kind of tricky right
but there are a lot of uh
good
contemporary philosophical literature on
that ancient and medieval and early
modern literature about about anger
and
so i want to say the the i remain
confused and isolated and angry yeah so
anger actually does confuse us and anger
does isolate us from other people and i
say this from experience
as somebody who got interested in
studying this stuff because i was an
angry person and needed to work on it
and like an alcoholic
i have not ceased being an angry person
in the sense of like i've totally left
it behind or anything like that
but you know it's it's managed it's
under control and i know that i have to
watch out for it in ways that maybe
other people don't have to watch out for
as much so maybe you can relate to that
i will say this it
as you work on these sorts of things
you you
your life begins to change
bit by bit slowly
uh and you
you get into situations where
you would have gotten angry or you're
still getting angry but you're not you
know like flying off the handle
and afterwards you're like holy crap
what happened here and well the answer
is you're you've been studying the
philosophy and applying it and it's
gotten better over time right so that's
um
that's uh
let's see yeah and i would i would say
you know go back to the aristotle go
back to
the stoics
check out what plutarch has to say check
out what the epicureans have to say
i've got a whole like video series on
understanding anger that goes up to
thomas aquinas
that might be helpful just at least for
giving you sources and stuff like that
um fires oh i we just did fireside uh
josh any promising young philosophers
you'd recommend
um
i mean i don't know i don't know a lot
of people
i've got promising young philosophers
i'm friends with mark smith who i you
know said hi to earlier is one of them
he's down in south africa working on his
phd
uh doing a lot of work on aristotle and
her rent
matthew sharp at deakin university is
putting out a lot of stuff on philosophy
as a way of life that's quite good
um
[Music]
i mean who else comes to mind
uh i mean there's all sorts of people
that you run across at conferences and
like you hear a paper and you're like oh
that's really good you know
i like what they're doing but then then
you forget their names or stuff i'd have
to go look them up
um
but yeah i don't really i don't have my
finger on the pulse so to speak right
um
[Music]
bastian is there any work on aesthetics
and heavy metal you could recommend us
to read
i don't know i don't i don't i don't
know any works on aesthetics and heavy
metal that come to mind right away
um i mean william
irwin has a book
no yeah irwin not irvine
has a book about uh metallica and
philosophy that looks uh promising i've
got it on my shelf but i haven't
actually read it
um
i would imagine in those like so and so
and philosophy books there's probably
some aesthetic stuff but i i don't read
a lot of aesthetic stuff and i probably
should you know
logic any thoughts on zizek
same thoughts as i have every time i
have an ama
uh i'm not really into him
he like habermas he writes way too much
stuff to possibly read and digest it all
um i tend to like his op-eds more than i
like his books i think that there's a
lot of interesting stuff but you gotta
wade through a lot of uh haystacks to
find the needles that you want in there
so
uh
sunny how do you tend how do you tend to
view
to get a handle on behaviorism as a
stance
in psychology but philosophy of science
so i don't do philosophy of science um
behaviorism is kind of implausible
um has been for for quite a long time if
we're talking about like you know
classic bf skinner style stuff
um i don't get a handle on it because i
i don't
i don't engage it you know
um
sunny fall sonny follows up how do you
weigh on logical positivism especially
as it relates to philosophy of mind
again i don't do an awful lot of
philosophy of mind
and i don't think that there's an awful
lot of people doing logical positivism
stuff out there other than like liam
bright you know
um
so it's it's sort of like asking you
know
how do you race that model t in the you
know the nascar races well
they don't use them in that anymore you
know
um
all right
british floof the second
says thoughts on duluth and or guitari
same thoughts as i have every ama again
i like to lose without qatari better
than to lose with qatari
you know the lose is is is uh
very interesting i like his histories of
philosophy
works uh you know like his leibniz book
and his nietzsche book and stuff like
that i i really like the logic of sense
uh essays critical and clinical
not as big on anti-oedipus or thousand
plateaus
but you know we don't all have to be
into everything you know right
uh bill
bobagans you help my friend with a paper
on aristotle and parmenides oh i think i
know who you're talking about
uh he recommended your channel he
believes that parmenides is an important
figure do you agree is it worth reading
the pre-socratics yeah parmenides is an
important figure
parmenides is also a paradoxical figure
and permanentes is somebody
who the great ancient philosophers
certainly thought or it was worth
engaging you know so aristotle
engages permanenties in the the
metaphysics and in the physics
plato has a whole dialogue
called the parmenides
um right which is
really weird
that it's displaying dialectic but the
first part is is is a lot more fun and
then parmenides comes up over and over
again right and in the later stuff too
and you know when you read the fragments
of permanity's poem that we have they
raised some really interesting questions
there was a great
uh discussion
of permanentes by the way in the recent
aristotle and the aristotelian tradition
conference
um the very first paper was by
um
a young scholar and i forget her name
from the university
of hawaii at one of the islands who is
working on advaita vedanta
and uh um you know aristotelian
metaphysics
and
um parmenides of course came up in the
discussion and it was really really
quite interesting so
yeah permanently is definitely worth
thinking about i i don't think you want
to become a parmenidean
because if you do then you're exactly
the same as the other par menadigans
because there's only one
this is where we get to the
paradoxicality of it but yeah he's
definitely worth
checking out and i do need to get back
to
uh the friend that you're you're
referencing who uh
uh
nice guy uh very thoughtful
um promising young student um up in
scotland
so um
dylan has one that i i can't really
answer well thoughts on whitehead's pan
experiment
experientialism is a form of pan
psychism
i don't really i don't have my head
wrapped around pan psychism well enough
and i haven't really spent much time
with whitehead
for a long time although i used to
really be into him as a undergraduate
you know i did make my way through
process and reality once i can say i
should probably reread that you know
it'd be good to do
but i don't i don't have any thoughts on
that um
all right bruno good to see you um do
you think nietzsche's trans valuation of
all values is a good idea why or why not
um
so i'll say two things one is
let's say that you wanted to be a
nietzschean and trans-value
trans-evaluate however you want to put
it you know
take the the vieta and shift them upward
and do so in a way that like doesn't
just go back to an archaic master
morality but like responds in a way for
the present
you sure as hell wouldn't want everyone
else to be doing that right it's sort of
like if you're if you're being a um
you know if you're being an egoist you
don't want everyone else to be an egoist
right if you're a nietzschean of that
sort you don't want everyone else to be
a nietzschean first of all they not
everybody could do it well but you know
it would also create a society that
wouldn't really
offer you the kind of uh space to do
that in that you you would want right
um
should everything be
re-valued
um
every single value
that sounds like a lot of work um and
i think it's more of a slogan
than it is a real
viable philosophy of life project i
think you have to be selective about
what you're going to
to trans-evaluate meaning to to change
you know from being
a
lower priority to higher priority or
being from uh you know evil
to to
good
as opposed to just being bad or
something like that so
yeah
uh
julia how to cope with rivalry at work
when somebody deliberately wants to ruin
your reputation well that's hard that's
that's
that's uh
one of those cases where you may in fact
have people who do ruin your reputation
you know we live in a world
that as virtuous as as we can be
or as squared away or resilient as we
can be um shitty people can do shitty
things to us or to those that we care
about
and get away with it so
you know part of it is to
don't get sucked into drama with them it
may feel like you're letting them win
some of the time but
um you know sometimes just letting them
do their thing
and uh protecting yourself
laying down you know boundaries and
limits and like correcting falsities
when they they arise but not like
getting sucked into like
a lot of conflict with them which is
often what they want
um eventually they they get tired of it
they move on because they're not getting
the the rise they want i think it i
think it is legitimate to to protect
yourself as much as you can
um rationally
and then you know realize that uh
other people being pricks rarely has
anything to do with you
so you don't have to take it you know i
mean it is tempting to like be what's
wrong with me that they're going after
me
you know is there may could they
possibly be right and a lot of time the
answer is no people are some people are
just pricks
you know and they you know here's an
index of it they get into that same kind
of conflict with everybody else you know
that's that's pretty much all that i
have to offer on that
um
kb thanks for all the long videos
on my favorite fantasy books i was
really surprised with a three-part
backer series have you ever read any
robert silverberg the name uh
is familiar but i don't remember
uh
if i have read silverberg i don't
remember what i've read
um it strikes me as maybe somebody i
read long ago
but haven't seen since
uh yeah on the backer ones i mean each
of those books is like
so we're talking about uh our scott
bakker's prince of nothing
uh trilogy which is the first part of
his second apocalypse the second part of
which is four books
in the aspect emperor
series which he never did follow up with
uh
as promised he's kind of fallen off the
map as far as i can tell but the first
three books which are very fascinating
stuff really well put together
um
each one is like 600 700 pages and very
detailed so there's no way i was going
to be able to do
um
a single session on all three of them as
i'd originally intended and as a matter
of fact
dan simmons hyperion
uh
kantos which is four books i'm going to
have to break up into
two sessions one of which we'll do this
year one of which we'll do next year
so it'll be the first two this year and
then the
set the
third and fourth
uh
the following year because you just
can't do so much stuff all at once so
all right um
mass act or any books philosophy that
counter biological reductionism
people who are likely to reduce people
to their iq genes etc
yeah okay so you're not even talking
about biological reductionism you're
talking about pseudo biological
reductionism because no good biologist
will reduce an organism
let alone a human being to such simple
uh
seemingly uncontroversial traits as that
right i mean
genes have to have expression and they
do so within social context
i mean you know one one
one thing that actually comes up in
terms of like jeans um that i was
teaching last week is richard dawkins
the selfish gene chapter 11 where he
talks about memes and he takes his
fellow darwinists to task for
having reductionist uh viewpoints on
like you know religion for example and
not that dawkins doesn't get things uh
messed up when it comes to that but um
you know that would that would be one
example um
i mean a lot of the a lot of the great
philosophers that are engaging
biology and metrics let's call it
um
would be worth checking out you know i
think you think about like hegel's
treatment of phrenology and physiognomy
back in the phenomenology
aleister mcintyre by the way has a
really great
essay on that called hegel on
faces and skulls in his edited volume on
hegel
and you know discusses similar things in
after virtue i figure i forget which
chapter it is but he's talking about the
social sciences
um you know nietzsche also was you know
good for critiquing that kind of
silliness
um
[Music]
and i think you'd find a lot of other
people along the way
uh
ksbv says if hegel were around today
which world leaders would captivate him
the way napoleon did and why trump putin
um
i don't know that there would be
any world leader
[Music]
that that would have sort of the
centrality for at least that part of the
world as napoleon did
um i mean trump is hard to take
seriously
as anything other than a
a corrupt
opportunist
who
you know
somehow
found his way
into catalyzing some of the worst
tendencies that the republicans had been
veering towards for the last 20 years
you know essentially he's he's a
continuation of the
tea party um
putin is uh
like trump is a weak man masquerading as
a strong man
i mean
not that napoleon was was
uh
absolutely great or anything but i don't
know that that they're like even close
to in the same category
um
[Music]
that's a good question i don't know i
don't know that we have
leaders where the leadership eggs are
all in one basket that much right
um and you know it's a good thing to
keep in mind too that hegel is unaware
largely unaware of what's happening
outside of europe
you know he's he he does like talk about
world history but his world history is
very very eurocentric
um
so you know who else was
important
at the time
you know we'd have to consider that i
don't know that i don't know that we can
i don't know that the frame of reference
works
for that but i mean if we're looking at
like world historical individuals if
that's the idea
who measures up it's a good question
i mean
there might be less
heads of government
and more
people
you know
involved in
corporations since there's so much
wealth that corporations have
appropriated to themselves and they do
modify our world
immensely
that's a good question i'd have to think
about that more
all right uh
kb
well stratagem says uh how do we define
free will we don't there's there's a
whole bunch of different things that
people mean by free will
you can define those uh and then you'll
find that the next guy down the road
doesn't mean the same thing by free will
you're not you're never going to get
like a consensus with everybody
uh
agreeing on a definition but it is
important to ask well what do you think
free will actually means because some
people mean something very expansive
like i can decide what to do at any
given point in time you know totally
free of my circumstances
that's probably a myth right
uh on the other hand and this kind of
goes to the next question by kb
sometimes free will just means that like
you got a little window of freedom and
you can use that and you like move out
of the deterministic uh
causality for a little bit and then you
merge back into it you know
so kb says i was just having a
conversation about determinism with
friends
i always like to describe my view that
there are certain rails of life and you
have the chance to jump between them
well that's not that's not a bad
metaphor um
jumping between the rails so like you're
you're heading i guess the the metaphors
you're heading down the road right
and you can like go on this side or you
can go on this side but you're going
this way right so
hans oled do you find any argument for
god convincing uh depends on what you
mean by convincing i mean the
ontological argument as articulated by
anselm who doesn't call it an
ontological argument where it's part of
a larger structure that is not just
about the
existence of god but the nature of god
and all the other things that we believe
about god as he says in the preface
i find pretty convincing
i don't really worry much about
arguments as modes of convincing people
because i'm not an apologist and i tend
to think that people who claim that they
shift from
you know non-theism to theism on the
basis of a single argument are usually
kind of weird
people that
miss out on on the rest of what you know
religion has to offer
hegel actually has something really
interesting that he says about arguments
for god's existence he says they're not
arguments to actually prove anything
they're not trying to produce conviction
they're actually modes of humanity
trying to figure out what god is
i like that idea you know so
uh prague's says happy happy 4th of july
is there a good place to look to see
how theological assumptions and axioms
still influence modern and post-modern
philosophical movements
um
i mean i don't know that they do
but
yeah i mean there's like a whole
shtick you could call it in continental
philosophy
of um you know criticizing onto theology
right you know allah heidegger that is
continued on to like people like
jean-luc marion
um and they tend to like
you know say that
even heidegger himself is not getting
out of al onto theology and there's a
lot of criticism of the medieval
scholastics and stuff like that i mean
atnj
has this in index scholastical cartesian
which
if i remember right was one of his
dissertations i think he was still in
the
the age when you had to do a latin
dissertation and a french dissertation
um
in in the french schools
and
that is a really interesting work
because what he shows is that
rene descartes is supposed to like be
starting from nowhere right he's
actually got all this scholastic stuff
that he's he's bringing in so
uh ali and elio nink would you say your
time teaching in prisons made you a less
judgmental and more compassionate person
um
if you mean by judgmental like being
irrationally judgmental yeah i guess i
mean i think people should be judgmental
they should they should engage in in
moral judgments about people and not try
to avoid that they should just be
judgmental on
solid bases right
um
compassionate yeah probably made me a
bit more compassionate
it really helped with the anger stuff
quite frankly you know um as i got to
know people and i'd talk with them and
i'd be like jesus i could have been in
there myself given all the you know
crap i've done in my life and you know
if things had gone just a little bit
different in this way and say i you know
really lost it and killed somebody
um you know
there but for the grace of god go eye is
the the phrase right and
so it helped me help i sometimes in the
past i would talk about it as i came in
you know with a lot of hard edges
and over time many of those were blunted
and you know worn a bit smooth
so i'd say that's that's true
matthias and gorgeous this is plato's
dialogue there's one argument that seems
odd knowing the fate of socrates
socrates says something like old leaders
weren't making people better as in the
end the deimos sentenced them to exile
it seems like a work that shows bad side
of socrates is annoying guy with poor
arguments that in the end starts a
monologue knowing that people had enough
of them talking and stopped listening
i'd say that's a misreading
[Music]
you know
he is being a rude guest but
this is also something that you know
these are people who like to engage in
argument
and and discuss things with each other
right so
um i would say that you you know you're
partly right but your interpretation
also goes too far in in the wrong
direction
um
[Music]
you know i'm not sure which argument
you're you're talking about because i
don't see an argument there um
but
yeah it was quite common for the people
to exile people it's called ostracism
right
and uh
that would happen with with people who
were
viewed with a lot of envy by by others
um
so yeah
no other voices sc what are your
thoughts on rising theocracy in america
i think it's a terrible idea
i think that many of the people who call
themselves christians in america today
are not only not christians they're
actually anti-christians
and um
you know it's not something radically
new we've had hypocrites and
you know uh political appropriators of
christianity
uh going going on forever right this is
a perennial problem
i think that um
you know it's interesting because if
we're going to allow
religious
determinations within the public sphere
then you know for example on the
abortion question get ready for
everybody else whose religious views
include the right to an abortion to
bring that [ __ ] forward right i mean
it's it's a christianity and it's
christianity of a particularly noxious
sort you know
um the people who
uh
they're not even you can't even call
them conservative catholics because
they're not conservative and they're not
even catholics within the catholic
church and then the evangelicals who
you know the jesus guy that they talk so
much about would not even like recognize
and would be calling hypocrites and
telling them the parables about how when
you know they go before the judge jesus
is going to say he doesn't know them i
think there's lots and lots of that
and i think people are using it you know
um
[Music]
using using that kind of stuff by the
way there's orthodox we're doing that
too and other mainline protestants
um
these are these are weak scared people
um for the most part led by
opportunists and uh cruel people
and they're you know they're clearly
going against what the gospel
preaches all you got to do is look at
the sermon on the mount right
or the beatitudes for that the part of
the sermon on the mount and uh
you know you
you can tell that these people are full
of [ __ ] you know and they really just
want to control other people
um
solomon salvador i'm a person who built
a system of reality a philosophy that is
atheistic i got a glitter of grace from
what i believe is god
but my system is keeping me in from
believing in god i'm going back and
forth and reading theistic philosophers
ain't helping what do you think i should
do
um i don't know
i mean
i don't know why reading theistic
philosophers isn't helping it might be
how you're reading them you know
um if you've got a i mean
if you've actually worked out like a
very
uh robust coherent system of philosophy
more power to you because that that
happens to almost none of us you know
i sure as hell don't have one
but i mean if you think that there's
something breaking through
then maybe you should read people that
talk about that like kierkegaard read
philosophical fragments and
try to wrap your head around that a bit
you know
and you know read the people that aren't
doing apologetics but i mean i always
say the most interesting religious
thinkers for me to read
are the people for whom
god coming in the picture or you know a
religion possibly being true didn't like
simplify things or settle questions for
them it just made things a hell of a lot
more complicated
those are the really interesting people
to read i think
so
all right um
yoda do you think certain philosophical
questions are unanswerable due to the
cognitive limits of the human mind
there's probably some probably not many
uh depends on what you mean by
unanswerable do you do you mean
able to like attain consensus there
isn't a single philosophical question
that there's a consensus on in
philosophy and that's a-okay you know do
you mean
you can't come up with a
reasonable answer to it that you find
workable and maybe a few other people do
too that's that's a whole different
manner you know
uh
thera decay what are your opinions on
gender is it true it's mostly a form of
expression i mean gender like anything
else is complicated
um
it's clear that it's not so simple as
the sexes are biological when they are
binary and oh my god we can't have this
sort of
confusion you know that that all these
right-wingers are so like
they got their panties in a bind about
you know
um there's so many people that are so
fear driven on this stuff but is it just
like well anything goes my gender can be
anything i want
no not exactly i mean
you know uh
there's something in between and it's
complicated and it's uh culturally
involved and
um you know it's also got biological
bases that don't completely determine
things and as we read through like
history and across cultures we see how
complicated this stuff is you know
i think people that are searching for
simple answers when it comes to this
are basically like
um
they either want to bash somebody or
they're fear driven
um
or or somehow they've been told that
unless you have simple answers for
things you know the answers aren't any
good and that's just not the case i mean
um gender is is a whole bunch of
different factors coming together
which do
coalesce in certain ways that we have
typically looked at as normal
but we might not a hundred years from
now you know and i'm cool with that
[Music]
max what do you think are oh this is a
good question what do you think are some
of kant's more intriguing works i
remember banging my head against the
wall sometimes trying to figure out some
of khan's epistemology
at first
um okay so i
like kant's second critique and third
critique way more than i like the first
critique you know people are always like
oh i gotta read kahn's critique of pure
reason well that's cool you know i mean
it's it's it's an important work in the
history of philosophy it's not like
the most important work
um and you know once you've figured out
conch stick you can decide whether you
buy it or not
um i think a lot more interesting stuff
is happening in the moral philosophy and
in
some of the other things you know and
he's got all these really cool essays
that are worth checking out like you
know
what is enlightenment and perpetual
peace i mean religion within the limits
of reason alone is much less a book
about religion and much more a book
about ethics
that's an interesting one um if you want
to see kant as a racist
uh
uh you know anthropology from a
pragmatic point of view
is is interesting to check out too and
then you'll be like wow
yeah
the stuff they're saying actually is
quite true but he also has things in
there like how to hold a good dinner
party you know so
that's that's all worth checking out
um
whitehead did nietzsche have some kind
of model of aristotelian soul when he
wrote that the soul is something in the
body
and thus spoke zarathustra i i don't
think
an aristotelian
soul because we're not even really sure
you know the the on the soul is a rather
underdetermined work you know um it's
one of the things of aristotle's
doctrines that
can be read in a lot of different ways
i i think nietzsche is kind of doing his
own thing there
i mean aristotle
here's one thing we can say we know
the soul is the form of the body for
aristotle whatever that means you know
um
i don't think nietzsche views it that
way at all
you know
all right a lot of nietzsche stuff here
uh brian collins been watching your
lectures onto android's dream of
electric sheep i'm curious what's your
favorite philip k dick novel and what
works of his would you most recommend to
philosophy students
so
for a long time it was man in the high
castle but in recent years it's become
uh
a scanner darkly i i think that is my
favorite of his novels
uh and it's a tough work you know um
there's a lot of his that are like
pretty close to like favorite like flow
my tears the policeman said
um
three stigmata is pretty pretty great
too although the ending isn't so great
right
uh and now what would i recommend to
philosophy students i mean
if you only had to pick one
um
i think the way to go really is to
android's dream of electric sheep
because there's so many cool themes
and you can also like show the movie the
blade runner and be like what happened
to this theme over here
where's this going in this film
adaptation why do you think that that um
the writer and director chose to go in
this direction rather than
than that one so yeah
uh captain of the nerd guard would
nietzsche have found anything useful via
implementing the dow to jing into the
philosophy over man
probably not you know
i mean nietzsche actually uses kinesis
chinese as a pejorative adjective so i
don't i i think that there's a lot of
things where nietzsche himself has got
some
got some blinders on as as mark schaeler
has pointed out you know for example in
his book on rosantomont so i don't i
don't think nietzsche would have gotten
that much out of it
um
jonty good do you have any tips for a
philosophy student for how to improve
their writing skills
uh no real tips i i just have the same
advice that ursula kayla green gives
about writing in general write a lot
you know and and keep writing and keep
writing and keep writing and you start
to get better at it and i guess the
other thing is you know be willing to
show your writing to other people
and
take the criticism that they'll give of
it because as my wife
who has taught writing for over
20 years
uh often tells her students feedback is
a gift you know so
all right we're coming up on
uh we're we're not gonna get to
everybody's questions it looks like but
we'll try to get through as many as we
can because we we've got a about
10 minutes left or so um
let's see it just scrolled up a bit
um
looks like there's a lot of back and
forth chatter
in here too which is fine
um
rep is lin is it linguistics or
philology the realm of study that
analyzes the bible from a non-religious
way
i believe the book of mark had some
serious modifications in the year 300.
it's a whole bunch of disciplines that
look at the bible
in
non-religiously committed ways right so
it can be
philology linguistics um religious
studies
uh history you know you go on and on and
on
um and i i don't think the book of mark
had serious modifications in the year
300 exactly i would i would uh take
whatever source is telling you that and
look at it with a bit of a jaundiced eye
because that sounds like one of those
things that bible scholars
who are on the fringe tend to say
um
all right
uh
i'm gonna skip down a bit
take some stuff from people that i
haven't
read from before
uh shikhar should one start with
philosophy
with starting from plato aristotle or
later philosophers a top-down approach
or a bottom-up approach don't know what
a top-down approach or bottom-up
approach means but if you're asking
should you know do you have to start
with plato and aristotle no you can
start anywhere the hell you want
you're going to reread what you're
reading anyway
as you accumulate more stuff it sure as
hell can't hurt
to start early on with
you know people like um
aristotle and plato but it's not like
you have to like go through their entire
works before you can go onto the next or
you have to deal with everything
perfectly chronologically i mean it's
your brain it's up to you to do whatever
you want there's a lot of i you know
i like metaphors and
or also analogies which i suppose
have metaphorical aspects to them
philosophy is like a vast
city
that you can
come into and get into neighborhoods
from all different directions
and
in different ways you can take the train
in you can walk in you can drive in
you can hitchhike
you don't have to come from the north or
the south you don't have to like i mean
you can spend your whole time in one
block if you want to which some people
do
but there's no like one single way to do
it you know
all right um
luke says what do you think about
marking or annotating inside your books
do you do it i don't do it much
uh i think it's helpful for people to do
then go ahead and do it it's not as if
there's
a single way to take notes or anything
like that right
a retrogamer gamer says hegel's lectures
on the philosophy where they published
in a book called lectures on the flaw
the history of philosophy
um which you can find online
you know googling or
probably at a good
library um
[Music]
let's see
a lot of uh
back and forth here
um
[Music]
all right um darth vader says in one of
the previous amas you mentioned it it
probably would have benefited
wittgenstein greatly to have read other
other philosophers who would they be in
your opinion
well
i mean there's philosophers that he read
but read inattentively
like for example augustine
because wittgenstein
early on in the philosophical
investigations talks about the
augustinian theory of language and
totally screws it up
and if he'd actually paid attention to
what he was reading in the early on in
the confessions he he wouldn't have
right
um i think wittgenstein could have used
a background in you know
um
the the very you know narrow canon of of
that time
and again i think that in many cases
wittgenstein may have read people but he
he read them inattentively um
[Music]
he was he was kind of like you know
stuck in the grooves that he was in
so you know he he would have probably
benefited from reading plato closely or
aristotle or
augustine or descartes you know
um
but i you know i don't really know
um
let's see
so here's a here's a good question from
telly are you a star trek or star wars
fan
definitely not star wars because i think
that you know
i haven't seen the the
episodes seven through nine
but i saw the prequels and holy [ __ ]
were those bad they they were incredibly
disappointing heavy-handed
you know
poor storytelling you know lots of cool
special effects but that's about all you
can say
and then and i went back and watched the
original three when when i my kids you
know i was trying to introduce them to
it and i was like
wow i
i guess we were really starved for good
sci-fi stuff at the time because this
stuff isn't that good
you know luke is kind of a whiny [ __ ]
um you know the dialogue sometimes makes
sense sometimes it doesn't really fit
that well
um it's kind of hokey you know but if
you put it up against like battlestar
galactica of the time or buck rogers in
the
25th century or some of the other things
logan's run right it was it was an
advance
um star trek i was into as a kid you
know i i watched the original series in
reruns and i liked it
on retrospect
it's okay it's not great i read books
too a lot of you know also i read alan
dean foster's splinter of the mind's eye
which was supposed to be like the the
second star wars thing and then that
empire strikes
back came out and i was like what the
hell is going on here right we got an
incoherence um
but i'm not i'm not like a big fan of
either one and i think that
you know sort of like with the analytic
continental divide there's other stars
out there stargate stargate was as good
as star wars
or
star trek i would say i would say
babylon 5
awesome
blue you know
star star trek and star wars out of the
water
really cool if they're going to redo it
recently watched my way through blake 7
and i was like this is some pretty
awesome
storytelling with some very minimal
budget stuff so i'm not really i'm not
really a fan of either but if i had to
pick one it would be it'd be star trek
you know
um
getting close to the end of the
90 minutes and i got to get something to
eat before oh here we go so trung uh
hello dr sailor how do you keep track of
all the ideas schools of philosophy and
their groundworks as well as relations
among them at the same time being able
to understand and convey them
i don't
nobody does
um the last time that that you know
people pretended to be able to do that
sort of stuff
you know like hegel he wasn't even doing
it you know or heidegger you know he
wasn't even doing it um friedrich
cobblestone
devoted much of his time to producing a
pretty decent
history of philosophy which has some
significant gaps in it but is is uh
probably one of the better ones
out there nobody nobody does that it's
just a question of how much you know i i
probably
have more
under my belt than than
most people
although there's probably some people
out there who know way more than i do
um but nobody nobody gets it all you
know and that that's kind of a
philosophical problem now isn't it you
know one that could could worry us a bit
um
oh here's a good one ethan bishop have
you ever wrote a philosophical dialogue
i have not i've never tried my hand at
that
there's a lot of people who do and what
makes a philosophical dialogue great so
it's got to deal with interesting stuff
but it's also got to be a real
dialogue i think it can't just be
as sometimes plato's dialogues are
caricatured as which i don't think is
really true you know socrates saying
this and then everybody's saying yes
socrates tell me more
that's not really a dialogue
um
yeah so i mean
one of the best philosophical dialogues
is the symposium and what i what i think
is best about that is like plato pulls
out all the stops
you know
the um people in the dialogue talk the
way that they would so aristophanes is a
comedian agathon is a rhetorician
the
medical doctor talks like a boring
stuffing stuffy medical doctor you know
and then you got socrates doing his
shtick you know i won't i can't talk
like these other people i'll just tell
you what it was like when i dialogued
this dialogue within a dialogue with my
great teacher diotima right who may or
may not have existed
um
so yeah all right let's see if i can
take one more thing to
to go out on uh and we'll scroll scroll
far down to get something
really uh uh new
um
[Music]
oh it goes here's a funny one kb that's
the first time i heard you curse and i'm
glad it was because you're emphasizing
the [ __ ] the prequels are
i curse like a the proverbial sailor a
lot of the time i don't do it much when
i'm like doing anything public
in part because it you know there's two
reasons
one is it distracts from what we're
talking about you know and it can lead
people to
um
pay more attention to the the cursing
than to the the content
and the other is um
you know
it's not very articulate i mean i i grew
up in essentially working class family a
lot of people in the trades
and um
you know i was in the army and
worked in restaurants and stuff like
that and picked up some some uh
less articulate linguistic patterns
um and uh so i try to
i try to avoid that that kind of thing
as much as i can but
um every once in a while it'll come out
i definitely don't do it with my my
young students in class
even though they they swear in class
because i want to like convey that we're
we're
doing something serious you know
so
all right well i have got to get going
i'm going to give you a little shot of
the city before
i take off
um
so
there's milwaukee you can see milwaukee
tool right there
they've taken over that building they're
going to have 2 000 employees
in that building with it's got the
little red milwaukee tool things and
then there's the
skyline so
all right thanks to everybody for your
questions and comments and stuff sorry i
couldn't get to everybody but we never
do
and i will see you later on we got a lot
of cool stuff coming up this month maybe
i'll see you
for some of those by the way uh anybody
who's gonna be there for classic metal
class we're now doing that on
light hall
so you have to sign up for it to be in
the class which is free
um and we're going to be talking about
rebellion in in heavy metal as a theme
so
all right i'll see all of you